we are teaming up for corn for today's
in a minute and my dear friend from Down
Under is here to show us how to make a
Barilla chickpea penne with a butternut
squash and corn meatless ground please
welcome Dan Churchill
well unfortunately we've only got a
minute all right so should I start the
clock go okay here we go so Drew over
here we've got just butternut squash and
onions into a nice little caramelization
medium I heat all right so now what I
want you to do just add in our beautiful
full spices you've got here some paprika
some nutmeg some salt and pepper and
that is all we need to do with this just
let it sit as it's getting to its point
of color and then add in our stock and
that's just going to reduce down we're
going to take half of that pop into one
of your beautiful blenders and it's
going to come out like this beautiful
creaminess yes I know I'm gonna pop that
how's it taste oh my God right
so into our grounders here along with
our butternut squash creamy goodness
we've got both those combined stirred
together whacking our pasta and then as
you can see you serve it up with some
Parmesan cheese and some parsley is that
a minute
all right so when you can transform a
vegetable that's healthy for you into
your favorite Indulgence that's money
and I love these meatless grounds it's
corn it's the company I work with it
just gives you this anxious yummy
delicious texture and it's all meat-free
foreign
[Music]